bonjour pas vraiment pitcho merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
juste une question de timing aussi on
voit que dans certaines régions du monde
en chine notamment et en un boulot m'a
dit tout à l'heure une recrudescence du
virus s'installe
la france elle choisit la fin de son
état d'urgence est ce que le timing est
bon alors ça c'est une donnée sanitaires
il m'appartient pas moins en tant que
jeu et ceux de commenter ce qui est
intéressant c'est effectivement ce
timing que vous soulignez essais ces
mesures qui sont prises en réalité
aujourd'hui nous pourrions sortir de
l'état d'urgence en juillet c'est ce qui
est prévu par les textes et le
gouvernement précisément craint la
résurgence de l'épidémie d'une deuxième
vague est donc à la fois pour aimer
aménager la sortie définitive et en cas
de retour de l'épidémie il prévoit dans
une loi qui a été votée par l'assemblée
nationale des mesures qui sont
transitoires et qui continue à donner
des prérogatives asselah significative
au premier ministre et au ministre de la
santé avec des limitations de liberté
vraiment importante qui interroge
aujourd'hui quant à leurs nécessités
donc le gouvernement se dote aujourd'hui
d'une possibilité d'agir qu'il ne met
pas en oeuvre mais qu'il conserve par
deux vers lui alors après la sortie de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire en france
qu'est ce qui va changer exactement pour
pour les français au quotidien alors
normalement nous devrions revenir à la
normale avec la possibilité
effectivement avec des horaires étendus
pour tous les établissements qui
reçoivent des pubs du public les écoles
qui rouvre est la possibilité de se
déplacer librement ce qui était déjà le
cas depuis la fin du confinement mais
qui va être étendue le cas échéant avec
la réouverture des frontières notamment
dans l'union européenne
mais avec ce donc avec ce texte qui a
été voté hier par l'assemblée nationale
et qui doit être soumis au sénat on
s'aménage la possibilité à la discrétion
du premier ministre ou du ministre de la
santé de pouvoir effectivement limiter
la liberté de circulation de pouvoir
limiter la liberté de réunion alors même
que le conseil d'état a dit dans une
décision du 13 juin 2020 qu'il n'y avait
pas lieu
limiter la liberté de réunion et puis
surtout on s'autorise aussi on en parle
assez peu alors que cette loi à deux
axes principaux on s'autorisait dans le
deuxième axe à conserver la totalité des
données qui sont collectés pour faire
face à l'épidémie
donc la donne les données qui sont
récoltées notamment par les
professionnels de sortez les caisses de
sécurité sociale les hôpitaux qui vous
permette en quelque sorte de tracer les
personnes pour cette lutte face à
l'épidémie il ya un vrai sujet
aujourd'hui sur ces données qui ne sont
pas seulement des données de santé mais
qui sont les données de toutes les
personnes des pays par exemple comme la
norvège je crois ont décidé de ne pas
conserver ces données du fait des
risques qui pèsent sur leur conservation
leurs transmissions et leur archivage
alors vous l'avez dit en france on
serait un peu sur un retour en tout cas
à peu près à la normale mais certaines
restrictions vont subsister un c'est
bien ça mais c'est exactement ça alors
on ne sait pas si ces restrictions vont
subsister on sait en revanche que csu
cesser ces restrictions peuvent être
réactivés à la discrétion du premier
ministre c'est surtout cela d'ailleurs
qu'aujourd'hui on prévoit effectivement
le 10 juillet de sortir de l'état
d'urgence mais en cas de nécessité pour
réagir d'une manière extrêmement
efficace
le premier ministre peut ordonner et il
peut donner d'ailleurs ses pouvoirs
aussi au préfet localement il peut donc
ordonné des limitations à la liberté de
circulation des véhicules des personnes
il peut ordonner la fermeture de
certains établissements on pense par
exemple au restaurant au café aux musées
et aux salles de spectacles sur un
simple décret donc c'est un outil qui
est très simple à réactiver et qui va
permettre effectivement d'une manière
temporaire limité de pouvoir rpt
prononcer les mesures de confinement de
limitations à la liberté du commerce et
de l'industrie
tout ça sous la menace ont plus de
délits qui ont été créés dans les
différents dispositifs sur l'état
d'urgence puisque les avait notamment un
fameux délit de violation répétée de
l'état d'urgence qui est réactivée en
quelque sorte avec cet état d'urgence
light provisoire elle pendant cette
période transitoire jusqu'à l'automne
alors on l'a dit tout à l'heure deux
départements français ne sont pas
concernés par la fin de cet état
d'urgence sanitaire les département de
la guyane et de et de mayotte
pourquoi gouvernement a décidé de
prolonger l'état d'urgence dans ces deux
départements en particulier
j'imagine que c'est du fait d'une part
certaines isolement d'une part et puis
d'une digue de l'âme du maintien de
l'épidémie aussi du fait de la capacité
des systèmes de santé locaux et qui font
qu'il ya un vrai risque ici pour ses
systèmes d'être submergées en cas de non
pas de résurgence mais de maintien et de
poursuite de l'épidémie
donc on peut imaginer effectivement sur
certaines zones du territoire une
réactivation de l'état d'urgence
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui est fait
effectivement vous l'avez vous l'avais
dit dans votre reportage c'est ce qui
est fait aujourd'hui en chine on voit
que pékin et sa zone sont à nouveau
confiné pardon sont à nouveau confiné et
cet état d'urgence transitoire qui va
être prévues du 10 juillet jusqu'à
l'automne va permettre précisément de re
confiné à certaines zones si nécessaire
merci beaucoup bonjour - peach ou
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin sur rtl
je rappelle que vous êtes avocat au
barreau de paris ancien membre du
conseil de l'ordre merci beaucoup merci